stehe hier in einem der gefährlichsten
orte der welt vor dem reaktorblock
tschernobyl 1986 in der nacht
explodierte
[Musik]
es war das größte atomunglück der
geschichte am 26 april 1986 passiert das
scheinbar unmögliche super gau in
tschernobyl
[Musik]
wir hätten uns einfach nicht vorstellen
können dass ein reaktor explodiert sie
explodierten einfach nicht während einer
übung kommt es zu einer kernschmelze in
block 4 des kernkraftwerks wladimir
iljitsch lenin nachts um 1 uhr 23
explodiert der reaktor niemand wusste
was zu tun war
wir mussten improvisieren
zehntausende sterben an den folgen der
nuklearkatastrophe
das gebiet ist für die ewigkeit
verseucht
[Musik]
33 jahre nach dem super-gau soll nun ein
neuer gigantischer sarkophag den
unglücksreaktor abregeln kurz vor der
fertigstellung reist bild reporter peter
tiede nach tschernobyl um als eine der
letzten einen blick ins zentrum der
strahlend helle zu werfen
[Musik]